because justin herbert was drafted one
spot after you i kind of feel like your
careers will always be intertwined you
know how do you feel about that
comparison that will forever be made
whoa i i just think that's you know
that's
just something that's gonna have to be
dealt with in the media i mean
i have no animosity towards
torches and herbert and for me it's not
even a competition between me and him um
it's a competition for
for myself to go out and you know
see what i can do to help our team be
successful against their defense
um
you know and i'm pretty sure it's the
same for for justin as well tattoo's
been a really great guy to watch um he's
been fun to watch and he's had so much
success over the past couple of years
that uh you know it's been great to
watch him and all the things he's done
so really looking forward to playing
against him this week and saying hi
you know wouldn't you like to see one of
these guys say
i really hate that guy i just despise
him
i want to beat his brains out you know
it's they never do that and and and
frankly frankly
how do i word this i think we've gotten
a taste of that kind of personality for
the last few years and i could do
without it for a while let me just leave
it at that um so uh that said herbert
and two are getting together this
weekend pick number five and pick number
six in the draft and this one is
fascinating it's kind of like peyton
manning ryan leaf light because the
dolphins could have taken either guy
they took tua herbert is the leftover
that the chargers settled for so far
herbert has looked better
than tua we've seen more of him
fascinating
uh match up and and and i hope they
cross paths frequently and in theory
they could play every year depending
upon where they finish in their division
but i hope we see a lot of tua and
justin herbert in the coming years
you know mike i i've thought this ever
since the draft and then early in the
season when we're all saying oh my god
look at justin herbert man was he pro
ready and you know looking back on hard
knocks
when justin herbert was very very
painfully honest about himself a few
times in that show about how oh man i
blew that one or you know he was very
self-deprecating
but the larger point is this mike
there was a little bit of an aura about
justin herbert coming out of oregon and
here's why
over the last two years when he got to
be a very prominent top ten prospect
okay what would happen okay nfl scouts
knew all about him but
the average people other than absolute
college football nerds or reporters okay
said i'm not staying up to watch him at
10 30 every saturday night
you know because their games are on
their games are on so late meanwhile two
is on the gary danielson game every week
you know he's on national tv almost
every week so you know everything about
tua
and you know about one tenth as much
about justin herbert and so i alway i
felt coming into this year
that of the three quarterbacks i said
burro he's gonna kill it and of course
he is
but the other two guys
we knew a lot about tua and there was a
little bit of a shroud around justin
herbert that he is just totally ripped
off in the first half of this season
and just the circumstances pursuant to
which he entered the fray for the first
time tyrod taylor the misadventures with
a needle aimed at numbing a rib injury
punctures a lung literally a moment's
notice for justin herbert and he never
looks back the only unfortunate aspect
of it is peter that the chargers haven't
been able to rise to that same level
they're two and six as my son said over
the weekend they must be the worst two
and six or the best two and six team in
league history
they're in every game they've blown
three 17 point leads they had a fluky
little almost won the game last week
horrible clock management down the
stretch so they would have had more
chances at the end zone to beat the
raiders and and as i said the other day
herbert is playing just well enough and
the team is playing just poorly enough
to get everybody fired after this season
because what a prime job that would be
if that comes open with justin herbert
there for the next 10 or 15 years
yeah i mean look
if they continue on this path
it's going to be very easy for
the spanos family to basically say we
got to make a change
i can tell you this right now mike they
absolutely unequivocally do not want
to get rid of anthony lynn they love
anthony lynn but you know you
you got to stop the bleeding at some
point
and and so this game becomes
really important just like the rest of
them do but you know look i'll say this
also about the dolphins
you know at the beginning of the year i
picked them to win the division and i
didn't really know why
i just knew that i really liked brian
flores i liked what they were doing and
i figured that at some point during the
year two would play and he would start
to if not dominate play very influential
football both running and throwing and
so far he he has it's only been two
games
but i think he's shown promise
but the thing about the miami team right
now mike that gets buried by
you know the tui show
their defense is really really good i
think their defense potentially is top
three to five by the end of this year
the pass rushing emmanuel ogba
uh the the
the uh the excellent play
to not let the perimeter players take
over games i think is really shown in
their four-game winning streak
yeah and consider they start at 0-2 and
they've really turned it around brian
flores is a guy that you have to
consider for coach of the year along
with a kevin stefanski in cleveland that
will be determined over the balance of
the season
uh bengals steelers on sunday crazy
issue with the steelers ben
roethlisberger has injuries to both
knees he's on the covet 19 reserve list
because as you mentioned earlier in the
program he sat next to vance mcdonald on
the flight home from dallas macdonald
turned out to be positive for covet 19
on sunday and was shedding virus they
expect ben to play jay glazer said last
night they're going to have a longer
practice on saturday not just a normal
walk through to help ben make up for
lost time but here comes boro with two
weeks to get ready and when i spoke to
burrow after their upset win of the
titans i i tried to yeah i just threw it
out there because you know they always
say we're taking it one game at a time
well he didn't he said you know the next
four or five games are very very
winnable and then it's like yeah
steelers coming up but he's not lacking
in confidence and that's something that
the bengals organization has been
lacking for a very long time i like the
moxie i like the attitude i like the
hatred the loathing of losing and i
wouldn't be surprised peter if they go
in there and and and steal one from
pittsburgh because pittsburgh has been
living so dangerously most of its games
the opening is there if the bengals can
can find a way to cram through it
i thought what was really significant
about the game against tennessee
not that uh borough uh you know didn't
throw an interception was very accurate
in the game uh played a very confident
game i watched a lot of the game played
a very confident game but the most
significant thing is first game since he
became an nfl quarterback that joe
burrow was not sacked
so i think what zach taylor is beginning
to understand and to realize is that
there are some things he wants to do
with joe burrow in getting him to sit
back there read read read
but now he realizes we may not have the
opportunity or the time to do all that
let's get the ball out faster let's have
him be a little bit more mobile in the
pocket
and that's going to become a strength so
to me especially in a week that you're
playing a great pass rush in the
steelers that cup be coming off a zero
sack game huge for zach taylor the play
caller and obviously for joe burrow
and that is the red flag for all three
of these quarterbacks the potential for
injury we've seen burro and herbert get
hit a lot and we know to his history
they got to stay healthy we feel like
you and josh and even russell before
that with the way the quarterback
position is going is this
is this what quarterback's gonna be
going forward rather not really having
the just the stand guy in the pocket
you're gonna have to have these guys
around as much as you guys do
i mean
if i was a coach uh
i i like a guy that can do both um just
because you know you got options you got
you know it opens up the offense a
little bit more you're a lot more
dynamic
get out of sticky situations
and then in football especially in the
nfl there's gonna be a lot of sticky wit
sticky situations because everybody's so
good
so that's just my that's my take on it
[Music]
calamari cardinals quarterback first
quarterback possibly to have 4000 yards
passing and a thousand yards rushing
he's on pace to do that through half of
the season and he's phenomenal and it's
easy to say
let him run the ball when no one can
catch him but boy what he's done this
year peter has been phenomenal and we
get another test this weekend and it's
as big if not bigger of a test than what
we saw last week when the dolphins went
to arizona and beat the cardinals and
kyler murray it's josh allen now fresh
from beating the seahawks
coming to town allen a guy who can run
the ball
murray a guy who can run the ball as
well as any quarterback who's ever
played the game a great great game
looming on sunday afternoon between
these two teams
i bet the nfl never thought when they
scheduled buffalo at arizona that it
would be a game of the week
i can't think of a time in nfl history
seriously when buffalo
again when the bills and cardinals
would ever have been the game of the
week
this the game of the week this week
now after josh allen sort of
resuscitated himself last week with a
great performance i mean that was a
tremendous performance out dueling
russell wilson i mean it helps that his
defense really badgered russell wilson
no pun intended
and and and obviously uh you know the
seattle defense was not as stout against
josh allen but
i'll just say this these two
quarterbacks the reason that it's so
cool i didn't think i would be talking
about kyler murray like hey he's a
threat to throw for 400 every week but i
mean he's thrown for 380 and 360 in two
of the last three or four weeks
and he's such a threat to run the ball
and mike
i look at kyler murray right now and
with we are in the golden age of nfl
playmakers
dk metcalf russell wilson patrick
mahomes deandre hopkins uh michael
thomas i mean there are so many great
offensive playmakers alvin kamara but
right now to me the most fun individual
to watch in the nfl is kyler murray
because his
running ability
is it it's it's more it's more of a
threat in my opinion than michael vick
was
because
he just has the ability to outrun
anybody on your defense
i i just i think he is
at the ver on the verge really of
exploding as a huge player in the nfl
you know i've said all year he's got a
combination of speed agility and
awareness that the nfl has never before
seen and people argue well what about
mike vick what about lamar jackson well
vic didn't have the awareness he got hit
too many times lamar jackson gets hit
too many times kyler murray will do
everything it takes for the most part i
think he let his competitiveness get the
best of him at times last week took a
big hit on a third and one play and i
think that's one of the reasons why they
didn't let him run it on fourth and one
and did a shotgun handoff to chase
edmonds instead but usually you do the
lateral hook slide the step out of
bounds he reigns in that desire to get a
few extra yards and show what he can do
he knows where everyone else is at all
times it's amazing it's almost like
peter
and and i think one of the things that
makes him so fascinating is because he's
so short it's like a kid got onto the
field and they can't catch him you know
and and that's what makes it like if he
was prototypical quarterback size it
wouldn't be as exciting it's more
exciting because he's so much smaller
than the guys who are chasing him
you know last year at training camp when
i met kyla murray
um
you know i felt like honestly i felt
like i was standing and talking to
russell wilson because they're my height
you know russell wilson drew brees kyler
murray even though kyla murray probably
is what an inch shorter than brees but
you know all about the same and you just
say this is really different when you're
when you're talking to cam newton you're
looking up like him looking up at him
like he's a power forward in the nba
but i think that really the fact that
he's kind of slight
and the fact that even though he when
you say he's slight you clap him on the
shoulder he's he's made a rock he he
really is and so to me
i think that really helps him the fact
that he's slight and he hasn't taken the
big hits and mike listen
the one other thing about kyler murray
in my opinion that we've seen
and we said hey there will be growth in
his game as he adapts from the college
game where you use your legs so much you
can't use your legs as much in the nfl
you've got to learn to be an accurate
efficient passer
mike the last two weeks kyler murray in
hugely competitive games
is a 74 passer and look that's a
snapshot that's not a career i get it
but that is a great sign that he is
taking that next step you're not going
to survive in the nfl completing 57 58
if you start to get to 65 66 67 that
without taking the huge hits
that is a long-term star in the nfl for
kyla murray
and there's so much they can do with
that offense as he gets more comfortable
we've seen more designed runs we see the
passing out of the read option look
which can can give a defense you know
you you combine you take the rpo and the
read option and you put it together
because a lot of the teams that do the
rpo their quarterback isn't a real
threat to run like nick foles in philly
a few years ago but when you have the
run threat by the tailback the run
threat by the quarterback the pass
threat by the quarterback how in the
hell do you begin to defend that on a
consistent basis when your guys are
stopping two or three different times to
figure out what the hell the play is
going to be and defenses i think are
going to be a key for this bill's
cardinals game
neither has a defense that you really
put a ton of trust in
and look the bills i think have a much
clearer path to the playoffs than the
cardinals because the cardinals are
caught in this cluster of nfc teams that
are all around five and three six and
two
somebody's gonna fall out of that and
not make it to the top seven
and uh you know for the cardinals for
all the impressive wins they've had
that loss last week could really hurt
them if they follow it with another one
to an afc east team that's coming out to
play them in their own building
yeah you know the thing that would
really kind of bother me about that loss
last week mike
is i thought they made a couple of huge
errors down the stretch
play calling and coaching first of all
kyler murray not completing on third and
one at the two-minute warning not either
completing a pass and to me
you know or running for it he threw to
kirk it was incomplete
to me if you're cliff kingsbury right
there
and you're down by three points and you
look at what kind of game this is okay
to me
you got to be in four down territory at
that point third and one with kyler
murray your quarterback you can't choose
to kick a 49-yard field goal period or
48 yards whatever it was and and again
look you ought to be able to make in a
weatherless place a 48 or 49 yard field
goal i get it
but it's not a gimme it's not an extra
point
and and to me that would bother me about
that you know sort of the thought
process behind that when you've got
third and one and you're at the two
minute warning and you have to score
and you why do you want to tie the game
and give the ball to tuatanga veloa
with two timeouts left i think and a
minute 55. it just
to me it made no sense but anyway it is
what it is so well i guess the valuable
speaking valuable lesson learned
valuable lesson learned by cliff
kingsbury too you'd send your kicker out
there and he can't make a 49 yarder it
comes up short you'll never do that
again
well i mean i should hope not but if you
can't but mike if you can't trust your
kicker to make a 49-yard field goal you
better get another kicker
i mean
you know especially in a climateless
place it's not like there were 20 mile
an hour crosswinds in front of them so
to me i mean i
look i don't know if they go for it on
fourth and one if they would have made
it or if they would have scored a
touchdown one thing i i don't know all i
know is that was a bad decision at the
two minute warning
yeah i agree with you completely when
you have a player like kyler murray you
know and that's where the analytics
has to yield to who you have who they
have how you feel about the play i bet
the analytics said what you got you guys
can do
yeah
well
kyler murray's skills tell me you got to
go for it and and uh hopefully that'll
happen the next time the cardinals are
in that situation all right seahawks and
the rams getting together a very
important game for the rams they're
clinging to the seventh seed right now
in the nfc
they win they move into a tie with the
seahawks and possibly with the cardinals
for first place i mean we could have a
three-way tie for first place in the nfc
west by the time we get to the end of
the day on sunday
here's aaron donald the all-world
universe defensive tackle talking about
the challenge that comes from trying to
defend a guy like russell wilson
well it's always a challenge when you're
playing against a you know a great
quarterback like him that can do so much
um
makes so much things happen with his arm
with his feet you know um so he he's
definitely
a special type of player you know make
her job a lot harder but we just got to
try to you know you know do our job as
far as up front to you know put pressure
on him make him uncomfortable um get to
him you know so you know we won't had a
so he won't have an opportunity he had a
day that you know that he wants so
you know the time i had him wrapped up
and he still found a way to get the ball
away
um so um you know it made my job harder
but you know we we definitely prepared
them and ready for that challenge this
week so
i don't know if he had something under
his shirt or if he just has muscles that
big on his back
darren donald
physical specimen
and
uh yeah donald trying to chase around
russell wilson and uh the seahawks have
put it all in russ's hands this year
because
what else are they gonna do the defense
was exposed yet again
yes they have dk metcalf a real
challenge this week with jaylen ramsey
on dk metcalf the running game
everybody's banged up it's not like it
used to be
um
this is this is a huge huge kind of
is this plan for the seahawks working
type of a game they fall to six and
three
maybe this let rust cook thing isn't
gonna be
you know the answer to what the seahawks
have been looking for as they try to get
back to super bowl form if they can win
it move to seven and two and strengthen
their grip on first place in the
division we're gonna feel differently
about it so that this is a huge i think
perception game how we're gonna feel
about these seahawks is gonna hinge on
whether or not they can go to la and
beat the rams
look
you know
it's the same old story we saw it at the
beginning of the year you know we said
that if seattle's defense is good enough
they're going to go a long way
mike
in the last three weeks
the seahawks have scored 34 37 and 34
points
should be enough to win they've lost two
of those games
and so when you look at the way they're
playing and look last week that's on
russell wilson he turned it over too
much i get it he handed buffalo good
field position and points i get it but
in general russell wilson is not a
turnover machine he just isn't
and and so now you have to hope
with jamal adams coming in healthy
theoretically now
and with snacks harrison probably
uh in line to come back starting next
week
for seattle i look at seattle as getting
two boosts to a bad defense that they
desperately desperately need and to me
it was just it was sort of a shame that
they were not able to to really uh make
a deal
for a really good pass rusher before the
draft never before the trade deadline
now carlos dunlop
uh is is a good pass rusher
but to me i really i had hoped for
seattle's sake that they could have
gotten ryan carrigan because i think
ryan carrigan's got a little bit more
left in the tank than dunlop does but
we'll see
and you know the fact that the defense
isn't getting it done maybe putting more
pressure on russell wilson to try to do
more and as a result
making more mistakes turnovers are up
for wilson and he has gone from being
the clear-cut no question no-brainer mvp
candidate to a guy who's starting to see
some of these other potential candidates
catch up to him patrick mahomes i think
is the one he needs to be concerned
about the most mahomes is having
statistically an off the charts season
wilson at one point was peter four
turnovers last weekend for russell
wilson you can't keep doing that and
keep the team on the right track and
maintain that kind of mvp presumption
every once in a while you get a guy who
gets that that shine
that feeling early in the season he's
the mvp
that's going to go away soon if they
keep losing and if he keeps coughing up
the ball the way he did last week
that's right mike and that's why the mvp
have always said this the mvp is a 16
game award it's not a week 9 award and
if i had to vote right now i still
probably would vote russell wilson but
you're right mahomes is having an
absolutely ridiculous year his team is
eight and one versus russell wilson six
and two and i get that but you know
we'll see at the end of the year
that's why
you know i really
you know every week when somebody says
well you know now the mvp is uh is
patrick mahomes and you know and i get
everybody saying well
you know now
such and such is the mvp
but really to be fair you've got to make
sure that you make this a 16 week or a
16 game award and don't go too crazy
with any one specific game
look at how one game though can change
the odds peter the points bet odds from
last week to this week it's tightened
considerably at the top between wilson
and mahomes aaron rodgers a significant
jump from plus 1 000 to plus 4 000 me or
400 meaning if you bet 100 you only win
400. it used to be just a week ago if
you about 100 you'd win a thousand tom
brady way down drew brees way up from
plus 15 000 to plus 4 000 and then
there's dalvin cook
the non-quarterback on the list who if
he keeps doing what he's done the last
few weeks he's going to be the mvp when
the 16th game is played peter
hey look dalvin cook
you know
i'm sure he really cares about this but
i mean he's been one of my offensive
players of the week two weeks in a row
and i hate doing that because in many
weeks you could just say hey give it to
aaron rodgers or or mahomes or whatever
so i try to spread it around but he has
been so dominant and in being that
dominant mike what you've seen
is that's the true meaning
of the most valuable player award you
know gary kubiak in essence has
basically gone away from this being kirk
cousins offense this is dalvin cook's
offense and to a much lesser degree
alexander madison but
this is an offense now that scares the
crap out of you just simply by running
the ball hey it's like what bill
parcells used to say in the 80s i
remember he used to say we don't have
many running plays we just keep throwing
a match and say hey stop us
and and for a long time with joe morris
and you know people couldn't do that
i think it's going to be the same way
with the vikings if the vikings advance
to go to the playoffs if they absolutely
right their ship and go to the playoffs
there's no question that you have to
give and and it continues like this you
got to give dalvin cook consideration
next test may be one of the biggest
because last year that running game fell
flat in soldier field against the bears
they'll get a chance to make it better
on monday night when they go back to
chicago one quick betting note before we
move to the next game i thought of it
when we looked at the mvp odds i don't
know if you saw this peter somebody
actually bet 99 000
on the packers at minus 1100 odds to win
straight up against the jaguars if the
packers win the person makes 9 000
if they lose 99 000 goes away forever
i don't understand the upside
but that's the bet that was made
well i guess you say
is jake lewton i don't even know is he
the quarterback playing for jacksonville
this week yes is jake luton going in
going into lambeau and slaying aaron
rodgers
honestly mike if i had money to throw
around i'd probably make that bet and i
know it's an on any given sunday deal
but how possibly
is uh
you know is that is that illogical the
thing now i understand
that the risk is big here obviously if
you lose but somebody betting 99 000
probably doesn't have to worry about
losing 99 000
exactly so why do you care about winning
9 000 right like who cares
it's probably part of it it's it's
probably part of a strategy you know you
make you probably make who knows maybe
you make 100 bets a week
and you just say okay i'm gonna make
bets on the following and blah blah blah
i mean gambling to me is insane because
nobody ever ever ever
is going to build a mansion gambling on
football and i know everybody said oh
well wait a second look at this guy here
look at this guy there you tell me over
a five-year period you show me any guy
who has won
68 of his bets on football
i will be shocked
it's just it's too hard it's too hard
and it's a ton of anxiety even if you
win and i think for me
the the the losses would hurt so much
more than the winds would feel good it
ain't worth it especially to put up 99
000 in the hopes of winning a measly 9
000. and let's move on by saying this go
jaguars all right 49ers saints
last year last year it was one of the
best games of the regular season the
fourth down catch by george kittle and
he's rumbling bumbling and stumbling and
it was awesome and the 49ers established
themselves now the 49ers you never know
what you're going to get from them i i
got to give kyle shanahan a ton of
credit for what he's made this team into
with so many injuries
but the 49ers lose 34-17 last thursday
night the saints destroy the buccaneers
38-3 i guess it would be fitting if now
the 49ers beat the saints peter do you
see that happening
i mean i think it is highly highly
unlikely mike i don't see how they can
give him a great game either especially
after what we saw with the saints last
week the problem is mike
these 49ers with this team and this
talent playing this week they can't
score enough they simply cannot score
enough and i don't just put the
the
really it was on honestly it was a
10-point game that they had against the
packers last week it was a garbage time
touchdown that made it 17 that the
packers are saying uh whatever
um so but but but i just don't see
any way right now that you know the
49ers the 49ers are going to have to
score high 20s to even have a chance to
win this game i just don't see it
yeah i i don't either but you know what
i thought the buccaneers were gonna win
last week too over the saints and we
ended up being wrong so you never know
that's why they play the games as chris
berman would say here's drew brees on
the saints that are now six and two
hitting their stride
i think each week we've gotten a little
bit better i mean it's been it's been an
unusual
season especially i think um offensively
over the last four or five weeks just
because of the amount of personnel
turnover
with guys being injured and that kind of
thing so
i feel like in a way we're just hitting
our stride a little bit um you know
getting michael thomas back i think he's
going to continue to
um kind of get back
into form um
you know with the more reps um and just
kind of coming back off the injury
emmanuel sanders as well
um
and and obviously just the more time
that we have together so
um that combined with the guys we
already have and the young guys that we
have that can contribute as well
i'm excited to see
our evolution
it really is impressive in hindsight how
they kind of held it together piled up
winds none were overly impressive they
had to come from 17 down on monday night
to beat the chargers
you know the games were not the old
school saints come out and steamroll you
until sunday night and now with michael
thomas back emmanuel sanders back from
two games that he missed due to cover
19. they used taysom hill
as well as they have at any point better
than any point all year reminded me of
how they used him in the playoff loss to
the vikings when he was the best player
on the field that day you throw all that
together
and the defense stepping up the way it
did the this you know every week the
perception changes who's the best team
in the nfc who's the most complete team
and that mantle passed from the
buccaneers to the saints last week
whether they keep it or not who knows
but for now that that that glow
is over new orleans
you know mike i'll tell you i talked to
both peyton and breeze after the game on
sunday sunday night
and here's one of the things that really
stood out everybody said well geez you
know kind of a slow start coming back
for michael thomas
but that's totally not the point
there's a reason why drew brees in the
first 19 minutes of this game completed
passes to 11 different players okay and
here is the reason big reason okay and
i'll give you an example the touchdown
pass to adam troutman the tight end
rookie tight end from dayton okay on
that touchdown pass if you look at the
wide angle view of that field you know
what you'll see
you will see split out way left michael
thomas
you will see split out way right who do
you think it'll be traequan smith maybe
emmanuel sanders no
mike burton and you know mike burton is
he's a fullback
okay so and and and it was kind of funny
the reaction i got from
peyton and and breeze was started well
they got to cover them
and so at that point when you look at
this play before the snap you can see
the bucks are not positive exactly what
they should be doing but
the saints counted on the safety
making sure that michael thomas does not
beat you over the top or on a fade
whatever okay so what they did is that
they capitalized on that they ran adam
troutman
right up the uh the post and he caught
an easy touchdown pass and my point is
everybody when they play the saints has
a plan but nobody thinks that it's going
to be mike burton over on the right side
as a as a wide receiver and adam
troutman catching a huge pass to help
win this game
and that's the genius of sean payton he
never stops looking at his ideas he
always believes he can implement plays
and his guys are smart enough to pick
them up they'll implement new plays in
walkthroughs in the hotel ballroom the
the morning of the game whatever it
takes
he is always constantly looking for
ideas that will work against the defense
that they're playing that week it's not
my system my way of doing things it's
who are we playing this week and how do
we best exploit the weaknesses that i
see
in their system and get my guys in a
position where they can be successful
and it worked as well as it ever could
last week 38-3 steamrolling of the
buccaneers a team that many including me
were starting to believe could be the
best team in the nfc
man my boy lamar got a gear not many
human beings got game recognized game no
he the og
superman
for him to be as successful and to make
the impact the big splash in
in this game you know not many people
have done it you know i say michael vick
i say lamar
you know i
you know i don't even think i'm in that
in that in that stratosphere i watched
camp since uh
you know um everyone in the country did
everyone know about cam superman you
know doing doing his thing you know um
and a lot of us looked up to him um he's
a mobile quarterback um he do his thing
he's he's a person who has who has took
this
this league by storm and especially
you know early on the doubt that came
with it i mean i i we all can relate to
you know being
a second guess question can he play he
got bus written all over him and things
like that and for him to succeed through
it all
you know makes him the true underdog
story that we all love to root for
cam newton lamar jackson
sharing appreciation for each other and
look two of the best quarterbacks in the
nfl getting together sunday night nbc
mvp last year lamar jackson mvp 2015 cam
newton peter i i agree with everything
these guys are saying
i i just i wish cam newton hadn't missed
the time that he missed because to me
that felt like the moment that you know
what they were building just completely
fell apart new england and they've been
scrambling to try to put it all back
together since newton caught covet 19.
yeah i agree totally mike i think they
were on the path
to be an interesting
probably not a playoff team but an
interesting contender this year and who
knows what the future holds but i tend
to think that any team that's down in
the closing minutes by 10 points to the
new york jets probably is going to have
to play for 2021. this has a potential
to be an interesting game
i think though that if i were baltimore
i would be thinking a lot about doing
what i do best and it's weird to think
that you have the mvp quarterback on
your team but to me
i have seen so many times this year
where they get the run going and it's
like
dalvin cook east you know they are just
absolutely unstoppable a lot of times
even without mark ingram so to me if i
were baltimore i would make sure that i
had two ways to go coming into this game
but i think i think that this is going
to be a game where they run the ball an
awful lot
eddie why are you wearing that
i'm here to throw a flag on any question
that i don't want to answer
no i'm just playing i just came for work
uh my other job foot locker so yeah
mike salar so you want to ask the next
one
[Music]
uh
is there a reason that you are working
at footlocker
um
well when you got a punter who is 100
uh
on the season completing passes man it
makes it tough on you so
trying to find another way to generate
some income
he goes with two jokes for why he's
dressed like a referee he never quite
answered the question but teddy
bridgewater he doesn't need the extra
money he's making 22 million a year and
he's earning it peter with the carolina
panthers he's been phenomenal this year
he's one of the sneaky outside comeback
of the comeback player of the year
candidates i don't know if he gets any
votes and and the fact that he played
last year and went 5-0 will actually
hurt him
but who would have ever dreamed he'd be
back playing the way that he is right
now
i mean look teddy bridgewater
to me i got the impression you know the
contract that they signed him to
seem like you know we really like you
but
you know if they really liked them they
would have given them a five-year deal
what they give them a three-year deal
right mike and and so to me
when i look at teddy bridgewater i say
you know they looked at him and they say
hey listen
if if you go one in 15 this year we're
taking trevor lawrence
you know so
that's what that contract said to me and
again look i spent a little bit of time
with the offensive coaches on uh on zoom
one day in the off season with teddy
bridgewater and i can tell you teddy
bridgewater absolutely totally won them
over in the off season and but there's
one other person in that organization
who's won me over and that's matt rule
how do you think the new york jets feel
right now looking at matt rule being a
very strong coach of the year candidate
now he's not going to win it nor should
he win it i mean my top three right now
would be number one mike tomlin number
two brian flores but number three would
be matt rule because he has made chicken
salad out of chicken feathers there i
really like the job they're doing and
that's going to be a very tough game for
tampa to win
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports